well Israeli media and the Reuters news
agency are now reporting that Israeli
troops have started withdrawing from the
Janine refugee camp let's take a look
back at the past 48 hours on Sunday
night Israel carried out air strikes on
an apartment Block in the Janine refugee
camp
by Monday morning the Palestinian Health
Ministry said that eight people had died
in Israeli raids overnight
that afternoon City officials said that
water and electricity had been cut off
and then as night fell thousands of
residents were seen there fleeing their
homes
later Israeli forces fired tear gas on a
public hospital where dozens of families
were seeking Refuge
by late Tuesday the death toll
engineering had risen to 11. well let's
speak to our correspondent Alan Fisher
he's engineering Alan when we last broke
the fighting was pretty intense we could
see the plumes of smoke hear the gunfire
there's been a lot of movement since
we're still hearing the odd explosion
and certainly in the air you can smell
tear gas that has been fired there was a
fire on the hill you can just see way in
the distance that it can Embers of it
but if you look down the main road which
has been our small window to what is
happening in Janine the road is now
clear of military vehicles and has been
for almost an hour now and vehicles that
aren't military vehicles and ambulances
have come down that road in the last
10-15 minutes which seems to suggest
that the Israelis have pulled back now
that would certainly fit into what we
had Israeli radio were suggesting that
the Israelis told the United States that
the operation in Janine would last no
more than 48 hours we're now at our 45
moving towards our 46 and also we saw
Benjamin Netanyahu speak in the last few
hours saying that what happened in
Janine was just the start of their
operations further afield and then the
Israeli military put out a statement
talking about what it said had recovered
from its operations engineering all of
these tend to be precursors to the end
of an operation and so I think what
we're seeing is although not guaranteed
that every unit and every Soldier has
pulled out of Janine that operation
certainly seems to be underway and it's
something that we've been talking about
for a few hours it was unclear for a
while because everyone Drew back and it
looked as if it was almost all over and
then they moved back in again that is
always the possibility we don't want to
get ahead of ourselves but certainly
from what it looks like and from the
people who know this area incredibly
well they seem to suggest that it looks
as if that withdrawal has begun may not
have finished but it seems to have
certainly begun Alan it's obviously
fairly dark now but in the morning I
expect we'll get a sense of the scale of
the destruction there
I think it'll be towards the morning and
I suspect that people will be reluctant
to move back into the area simply
because when it's dark and there's no
electricity in the camp and two it's
getting late so that is an issue and
three they're not entirely sure that the
Israelis have all gone and so they
wouldn't want to put themselves at risk
that could still be snipers around there
could still be the odd unit around no
one would want to make that mistake in
the dark and so I suspect that most
people who are and there's more than 3
000 people have left uh genuine refugee
camp in the last 48 hours they will wait
until the morning before going to see
the damage in the home because to be
honest at this time of night there's not
a great deal they can do other than just
make sure that their home is there and I
suspect that it'll be come the morning
many people will want to know that yes
the Israelis have definitely gone and
two that it's safe for them to go back
they've been through an awful lot in the
last 48 hours the last thing they want
to do
is to create a fatal mistake in in what
seems like the the last few hours of
this assault speaking of which Alan I
can hear the sirens there just behind
you we've been speaking about how
medical access was restricted to people
in the camp including those who had
sustained some pretty serious injuries
do we have a sense of of the casualties
yet in terms of what's happened over the
last 48 hours or will that also have to
wait for morning
I I again that will be an assessment
that will be made by the International
Red Crescent the local red crescent
Association and also Doctors Without
Borders groups that have been saying
that they haven't been able to get easy
access to the camp that there may still
be people trapped in the center of the
camp where the worst of the fighting was
where they were restricted by the
Israeli Army from approaching and it was
difficult for people who were injured
and wounded to get out so at the moment
we know that there's still 11 people who
have died uh we know that more than 100
people were wounded the 20 of them are
in critical condition in fact there was
news just a couple of hours ago that one
of those in critical condition had
actually died that took the death toll
here to 11 after he had been shot in the
head during the operation uh I think
we're just is there an update just give
me one second here we're just getting an
update as we're monitoring local media
as well so if you just bear with me a
second uh it's yeah so just as we were
talking about the whole safety issue uh
we've just received a call from from
locals who are in there and they're
suggesting that there are still snipers
they can still hear and see snipers in
the camp so that would make it uh the
people would be very reluctant to head
back into the camp uh at this stage when
it's still dark and they essentially
don't know what they're walking into of
course and Alan we've been seeing some
pretty terrifying video of the
experiences of some of the the civilians
the residents there of Janine over the
course of the last 48 hours can you talk
us through some of the experiences that
you've been hearing about
yeah if you can bear with me just one
second we're getting another update so
this is all pretty fluid
there's been a we're just hearing that
there has been a targeted strike uh
close to or actually on the cemetery and
that has happened pretty recently so
while we're aware that there are fewer
Israeli soldiers here that we can see in
our small window the operation to a
degree is still continuing so this
hasn't been a fool and complete
withdrawal so that is still ongoing at
the moment and we're speaking to people
uh
even as we're uh we're on air here sorry
I've completely forgotten the question
you asked Alan I was asking you about
the experiences that people have been
living through over the last couple of
days we were talking earlier and and
watching some of the really terrifying
videos
um especially the women and children did
the experiences that they've been going
through
well you'll remember that this Camp has
been established for for dozens of years
and people have experienced over the
years a number of incursions including
if you go back to the 10-day assault on
Janine during the second in the father
in 2002 but the more recent assaults
have certainly not been anything of this
lens the one just last month lasted 10
hours so this was an extended period and
people were scared they were terrified
and we saw that and we've seen it in
pictures and of course we now have a
better insight into these things because
of of user generated content of people
who will post it to social media and we
get a much better insight into the
difficulties that people have had during
these operations and obviously with the
Israelis telling the Americans that this
operation will be done in 48 hours the
impact the consequences of what has
happened here over 48 hours will be felt
for much longer than that you're talking
not just months but perhaps even in
years Alan Fisher there with all the
latest for us on the ground in Janine
thank you so much Alan